♪ ♪
>> Hannity: DEMOCRATS BEEN
LYING TO OUR FACES FOR YEARS AND
NEVER THE BORDER WALL, MEMBER
WHEN DEMOCRATS CALLED IT RACIST
AND DANGEROUS AND UN-AMERICAN
WHILE LOOK AT THIS, WHAT A
TURNAROUND OF 180.
JOE BIDEN IS NOW ATTEMPTING TO
FINISH THE WALL HE'S TRYING TO
DO IT IN SECRET WE HAVE A FULL
REPORT WE WILL EXPOSE IT COMING
UP ANOTHER LIE FROM DEMOCRATS
MEMBER WHEN THEY TOLD US THAT
SOCIETY WOULD BE BETTER AND
SAFER MORE EQUITABLE IT WE JUST
GOT RID OF CASH BAIL AND DEFINED
POLICE DEPARTMENTS VIOLENT CRIME
IS NOT SPIKING, AND MURDER AND
ASSAULT ARE ALL ON THE RISE IN
AVERAGE AMERICANS ARE BEING
HEARD THE MOST YORKS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DOESN'T CARE RIGHT TO
SHOW YOU HOW NEW YORK CITY IS
BUT ONE CITY RUN BY D.A. ALVIN
BRAGG AND IS TURNING THAT CITY
INTO A PLAYGROUND FOR CRIMINALS
BUT FIRST WE'LL BEGIN WITH
ANOTHER BIG LIE FROM DEMOCRATS
THAT IS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT THEY ARE CALLING THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT AS
ANYTHING BUT LET ME BE CLEAR IT
DOES SOMETHING TO REDUCE
INFLATION IT WILL INCREASE
INFLATION.
IT IS A $400 BILLION GREEN
ENERGY BOOM DOG THAT WILL RAISE
TAXES DRAMATICALLY BY THE WAY
YOU WILL CUT PAY THE COST OF IT
IT WILL INCREASE COSTS FOR EVERY
AMERICAN ACROSS THE BOARD IN
OTHER WORDS IT WILL MAKE
INFLATION FALL WORSE.
SO WHY ON EARTH SELF-PROCLAIMED
MODERATE DEMOCRAT SUPPORT THIS
BILL?
APPARENTLY HE WANTS TO BE WILL
COME BACK I GUESS AND TO THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP AND POLITE
SOCIETY AND OBVIOUSLY HE THINKS
THAT THE PEOPLE WEST VIRGINIA IF
THEY WON'T NOTICE SO THEY WON'T
CARE THEY WILL BLAME HIM FOR
INFLATION AND RISING ENERGY
COSTS BUT THE PEOPLE
WEST VIRGINIA THEY'RE NOT STUPID
HE IS TO BLAME HERE SO IS EVERY
OTHER DEMOCRAT THAT'S BEEN
FLAMES OF YOUR DOLLARS TO
APPEASE CLIMATE ALARMISTS SAVE
THE PLANET CALLED THE NEW GREEN.
OF COURSE THIS INCLUDES
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF THE BIG SLAYER
OF THEM ALL THIS WEEK MORE
HORRIBLE NEWS THROUGHOUT EVERY
TURN EVERYDAY THIS WEEK WE GOT
BAD ECONOMIC NEWS ACCORDING TO
JOE LIFE IS GREAT HE WON'T EVEN
ADMIT THAT THE REALITY THAT WE
ARE IN A RECESSION.
HE WON'T EVEN ADMIT THAT RISING
INFLATION IS A CRISIS WHICH BY
THE WAY CONTINUES TO GET WORSE.
IN ONE ECONOMIC INDICATOR TRIED
BY THE FEDS CAME OUT TODAY THAT
THE PERSONAL CONSUMPTION INDEX
JUST JUMPED TO A FOUR DECADE
HIGH.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYTHING IS A
FOUR DECADE HIGH.
WE THINK INFLATION IS BAD NOW
JUST WAIT UNTIL CHINA INVADES
TAIWAN, SADLY THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING NOTHING TO FORCE CHINA'S
MALIGNANT DICTATORSHIP AND
PREVENT YET ANOTHER GLOBAL
CONFLICT CHINA JUST THREATENED
AMERICA ON THE PHONE CALL
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT AND TOLD
US THEY BETTER NOT BE PLAYING
WITH FIRE WHAT A JOE BIDEN DO?
NOTHING.
TODAY THEY THREATENED TO
ASSASSINATE THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE NANCY PELOSI TO BLOW HER
PLANE OF THE AIR IF SHE DARES TO
VISIT TAIWAN WHAT A JOE BIDEN
DO?
NOTHING.
SO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CONTENT ON DOING
NOTHING AND COWERING IN FEAR
WHAT IS STOPPING CHINA FROM
INVADING HER UNIFYING WITH
TAIWAN?
WHILE PUMPING EVEN MORE FAT AND
ALL INTO OUR COUNTRY ARE
STEALING MORE OF OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY ARE NEV